「日本で好きなものは？」とよく聞かれる。
相手が同年代の男性ならいつも「Rio」と答えているが、
そうでない場合は「歯医者」と言っている。
僕は日本の歯医者が大好きだ。
それは、２０年間アメリカの歯医者に通っていたからかもしれない。
品川の新築マンションのリビングみたいな、清潔で心地良い部屋。
電球が見えないように天井の端が二重になっている。
どこからともなく小川の音がしている。
乳白色の革製ソファ。
暗めのフローリング。
ファブリーズのハワイアンフラワーの香り。
入り口の反対側の壁には６０インチはあるかと思われるソニーのBRAVIAがかかっていて、
「世界のパワースポット」…
的な番組が流れている。
ギザの黄色いピラミッドと
ジュディマリのYUKIさんに似た可愛い女の子のガイドが映っている。
映像が綺麗で、
画質の良いテレビというより、
むしろ窓越しにエジプトの砂漠を見ているという感覚だ。
YUKIさんがピラミッドの頂上を指差して微笑む。
高さは４６０メートルだ。
部屋の中央には黒い艶消しの低いコーヒーテーブルがあり、
その上には青い花を三本挿したガラスの花瓶が置いてある。
隣には何かドイツ語らしい言葉の刻まれた、
貝みたいな小さな白い彫刻。
部屋の隅では羽のない扇風機が悠々と顔を振りながら涼しさを掻き回している。
他の患者はみんな窓の向こうのピラミッドを静かに眺めたり、
ファッション雑誌のページをパラパラめくったりしている。
目を閉じたら無意識のうちに蓮華座を組んで座禅を始めてしまいそうなくらい、
平穏な環境だ。
蒲田駅まで徒歩２０分の、
昭和３５年築の、
コンクリート造りのアパートの、
コンクリート造りのアパートの、地下の
コンクリート造りのアパートの、地下のボイラー室。
そんな雰囲気を醸し出す。
窓もなければエアコンもない、
今にもゴキブリや王蟲がぞろぞろ出てきそうな、窮屈で蒸し暑い部屋。
アンモニアと漂白剤の臭い。
椅子ともフットレストともつかない、何か大きくて丸くて黒いもの。
空港の通路にあるような、
渦巻き模様のずっと連なったカーペット。
素材が余ったのか、それとも
壁紙が足りなかったのか、
壁も同じカーペットで覆われている。
ところどころ、ナッチョチーズのように見える染みが付いている。
近所の映画館が捨てたカーペットなんだろうか。
天井にはコンビニや銀行の警備モニターを思い出させる小さなテレビがかかっていて、
灰色の棒グラフが二つ映っている。
画質はゲームボーイカラーとゲームボーイアドバンスの中間で、
スピーカーからはモールス信号と３２キロバイトのポッドキャストの混ざり合ったような雑音が流れている。
部屋の中央には金魚の水槽がある。
子供たちが見て楽しめるように置いたんだろうが、
ガラスは指紋だらけで、
金魚たちは深緑色の人工ミニ珊瑚礁の後ろに集まっている。
騒がしいアメリカの子供たちのおかげで、
金魚は「うんざり」という気持ちを知っている。
モールス信号と一緒に、ドリルの甲高い音と子供の叫び声が聞こえる。
５秒以上目を閉じていると、
シリアの拷問施設にいるように思えてくる。